[Music]
thank you
thank you
thank
you okay assalamualaikum
salaam thank you clearly the gsb is very
excited to have you here today um
before we start we'll just say a
personal thank you malala
as a fellow pakistani
a brother to two sisters
a son to a mother back in karachi
is i'm humbled and filled with gratitude
to share the stage with you today
thank you so much and i'm also honored
to be here thank you so much to everyone
for your presence and i'm so excited
to have this conversation great there
are a lot of important topics you have
to cover today you don't have too much
time
i want to start with one which is very
important to the both of us yes that's
cricket
um
have you been following the world trap
in the last week
yes i i always follow cricket and i even
like
i would watch
any league any any match that is to do
with cricket
and i watch test matches as well that
are five days long
um but t20 is is the shortest you know
in the international ones
and pakistan is doing really well this
time
started with india then
we beat them then new zealand again we
won
and today it was afghanistan we won
again
um i think in the last two overs a lot
of people had given up and they thought
pakistan was going to lose but i had
full faith that pakistan was going to
win today and my intuition is never
wrong wow there you go
um
great so let's perhaps start with
pakistan
before you were even 10 years old back
in swath
um you were a loud advocate in your
community for trolls education and
drills being in school that's not i
would say typical of a 10 year old girl
in pakistan what made you do that at
that early age
i think uh you know people often time
hear about my story and they are
surprised that i was speaking out for
my right to education at age 10 11
and it is an unusual story but also
this was the case because what i was
experiencing was unusual for girls
and that was because at that time the
pakistani taliban had entered swath
valley
in 2007 they started spreading this
ideology of establishing the so called
like islamic state
and they wanted to bring in their own
so-called sharia system
and they
you know they wanted to like pakistan
was already an islamic country so like
how do you make another islamic country
inside in in an islamic country but then
along with that they also had this
narrative against women
and
you know they carry a very patriarchal
mindset as soon as they entered they
banned women from going to markets they
banned women from having any profession
from going to work they would not allow
them to go
outside their houses without you know
wearing a full shuttle [ __ ] burqa and
you had to have a custodian with you you
know it could even be like your little
brother and i remember like my mom or me
or any woman like going outside uh you
know to see a doctor or somebody and
they would have like these little boys
with them you know you know i would
always question like how's this little
boy going to protect me right like they
can't instead i'm protecting them
but at that time they also announced a
ban on girls education
and
i could not go to school my friends
could not go to school so i had no
choice
but to speak out for my right to go to
school
and i want to touch on
the role your father played xiaohin
you've spoken about him previously
how much of an influence was he
in that upbringing at that early age
especially when it comes to education
i'm really proud of my dad he
uh is is a proud feminist
and he saw that his own five sisters
could not get their education uh and
they
uh you know they did not have access to
a future that he had
and he knew that his life was different
because he was a boy nothing else
gender played a role in deciding the
destinies of of the siblings
and he was really passionate about
uh bringing equality into society so he
decided that when he has his own
children he would
ensure that they're not discriminated
based on their gender
and
you know he has always loved me and uh
he um
you know he has been a proud dad he has
encouraged me to believe in myself and i
always tell people that my story
is not an exceptional story
it could have been the story of any girl
if their fathers and their brothers had
allowed them to speak out
many were stopped by their family
members many were stopped by men in the
society what's different in my story is
that my father did not stop me
so um and that's what he says
when you ask him you know like what did
you do for your daughter he says that
like don't ask me what i did but ask me
what i did not do and i did not clip her
wings so it's a message to women and
girls all all around the world that you
know that they don't need any sort of
superpower or anything special to go
ahead in their life there are so many
barriers in front of them that makes it
more difficult for them to go ahead so
we need to fight against those barriers
the glass ceiling the iron bars
uh in their way and men have a role to
play in that so
for me like my dad has always been
supportive
and
i have always
you know been this sort of like i like
giving advice so i'm always there
telling my dad how things should be and
what we should do you know when you're
like a kid and you you know that's your
thing and that's how you talk to your
family members so i have carried it on
since then but he always listens uh he's
he's a great dad right
and just um on your father
um i read somewhere that he also named
you malala it's a beautiful name
can you tell us more about
the story behind your name
uh so
malala means grief stricken basically in
pashto
but the name has more historical meaning
as well and it was the name of this
afghan heroine malalai of maiwand
and she came from this maywand area in
afghanistan and her story is goes like
this that there was the second
anglo-afghan war and the afghan soldiers
were
losing that battle and they were leaving
the battlefield when this uh
young woman went to the mountaintop and
she raised her voice and told the
soldiers
that if you do not die on this
battlefield today you will live your
life in shame forever and her voice was
so powerful that all the soldiers
returned and they fought that war and
and they won
you know it's i think it has
meaning it has more meaning in our in
our culture and uh she is probably the
only
uh pashtun hero that we have
who is known by her own name
and so my father was just really proud
of her and he wanted to name me after
somebody who had was known by her own
name right i think that's beautiful just
based off the life you've lived so far
and how it mirrors malala and and i know
that story
so let's perhaps just move on um fast
forward a few years you're 17 years old
now this is late 2012 early 2013
after the taliban attack
you're um recovering the monster rolling
by you're in a different country or in
the uk um
take us back to that time and you know
it's a time of you know helplessness of
despair you've gone through such a lot
how did you think about what you wanted
to do next in your life and kind of just
put us in that position and how did you
think about that
so when i was in the hospital i
had no idea that i was receiving so much
support from around the world i was not
seeing any television any mobile phone
and
i was going under
you know
all the health care and treatment and
then one day this staff member had the
hospital brought this basket of cards
and letters
and i was opening those cards and
reading messages from people
from all over the world you know a
letter from a five-year-old girl to a
letter from an eight-year-old person
in the u.s or in japan and i was
completely amazed and surprised that
uh people had heard my story and they
were sending their prayers and they were
sending me even like gifts like you know
from shampoo to
scarves to shoes to anything you could
possibly think of
and you know i was i was completely
amazed and then the staff member told me
that this is just one box there are like
so many boxes there with us you have
received thousands and thousands of
cards from people from all over the
world that's when i realized that i
you know i
can
speak out for girls
globally i you know the taliban tried to
silence me but you know they made a huge
mistake
because i'm in a position where i can
not only speak about
my right to education and girls and for
girls in swath valley but i can speak
out for girls globally and since then it
has been my mission to ensure that all
130 million girls who are out of school
can have access to education that's
beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's the mission the 130 free safe
quality education for clothes around the
world how did you come up with the idea
of a fund or a foundation
um you know who kind of who helped you
who guided you at that early age data is
done of what us through that process of
why the fund was the best vehicle um
to achieve that mission
um so i'll be honest when i you know
when i started this foundation i wasn't
really sure how these things worked i
was i think 16 years old
i was also
studying i was
i was a bit behind in my studies because
because i had missed a few years
because of my treatment so
i had i had to do my homework and i had
to
be in school and then i had to do these
events
because i was invited to different
places
and then i started a foundation as well
called malala fund and initially when i
was asked
what do i want to focus on and
uh i said you know
on girl's education i want all girls to
be in school that's what i want to work
for but then they said no no like you
have to be a bit more specific do you
want to work
you know in this country or that country
and do you want to like build schools or
do you want like so many questions i was
like no like i want to do everything i
want all girls to be in school i can't
pick
this has been the mission uh
for us since then that we fight for all
girls who are out of school and we
currently work in more than eight
countries including pakistan nigeria
brazil india afghanistan
lebanon and
our mission is to ensure that we work
with local
activists and we support the local led
projects that address the issues and the
barriers that girls face in their uh
pride to education so it could be from
like training female teachers to
changing legislations to addressing
social norms and engaging the local
communities and the work has been
remarkable when you work with local
activists because they identify the
problems but they also identify
solutions to those problems
that's great you mentioned earlier
studying um you graduated from oxford
last year
in the summer but you've been an
activist
well before that you know before oxford
back in swath and since um you know the
attack as well
what did you get from that classroom
education um i believe you're at ppe at
oxford
what how did that classroom education
over those three years change your view
on how to approach this problem and just
your approach and advertising and
activism compared to what you knew
before
um i'll be honest when i was studying at
university at oxford um
you know education was still important
to me but
it was not a priority because
they tell you that you know you you
learn a lot from your textbooks and from
your lectures but you also learn a lot
from meeting people and socializing with
people
and i will be honest i met incredible
people there i made amazing
you know friends and
i i'm friends with them now forever and
i also got the opportunity to engage and
interact with incredible professors and
um
and you know these amazing intellectual
people whose you know books i'd be
reading for my essays so
it's just great to have that opportunity
and then like oxford is just so
beautiful so you spent a lot of time in
the beautiful gardens and libraries
there
and you spend amazing time with your
friends and then you go through essay
crisis and then
you are you're you're awake the whole
night just to finish your essay that you
left to the last date
i mean it's it's your fault and every
week you are just depressed why did you
did the why did you do this to yourself
again
but it happens uh and then you know you
don't regret having all those incredible
experiences so you're like fair enough
and then you submit your essay
and go back to sleep at 8 a.m in the
morning
i'm sure there are many people who can
relate to that experience
you shouldn't be so hard on yourself um
i want to go back to the funds mission
um 130 million girls um
who you want to get back into school k
through 12.
this last few months in the last year
has been difficult for that mission on a
number of different reasons um
perhaps let's just go back to august of
this year the taliban recapture
afghanistan
how did you receive that news how did it
sit with you what was your initial
reaction having already lived through
that you know nine years previously
um
no one expected the taliban to take over
afghanistan no one and i remember just
like two weeks before the taliban took
over kabul i had a call with all the
activists that we were supporting in
afghanistan like our education champions
there and some of them still had hope
that
uh that you know
that afghanistan can never fall into the
hands of the taliban and they
uh so you know just like everyone else
the whole you know the whole world was
shocked i was shocked as well to see
that uh that the taliban
were now in uh you know in the whole
country and they were ruling over over
people
and
you know i think it it's again a gloomy
time for women and girls there
and we already see the impact of that
women
have lost the opportunity to walk freely
to their
job places many of them have not
returned to their workplace
and girls at this time
are not sure if they can go back to
schools or not the taliban announced i
think 43 days ago that
boys can return to schools but they did
not give any clear statement on whether
girls can return to their schools or not
so uh you know we started then a
petition together with afghan activists
and
it's on awas.org and we are asking the
taliban to
immediately
let girls be in schools we are also
asking g20 leaders and the muslim
countries to take
you know a bold stand for this they must
protect the rights of girls and they
must protect the right to education for
girls
afghanistan right now is the only
country in the world where girls are not
allowed to be in school
and just on that issue malala sometimes
it's difficult for us to
you know visualize the 130 million girls
we're not in school we're where you're
at stanford in california you know dare
i say much very much a bubble compared
to the issues that we're all seeing on
the front lines
can you help us understand why is this
not just a women's or a drills issue but
an issue for everyone and this is not
something that you know countries in
another part of the world need to worry
about but this is truly a global issue
for everyone around the world
i think firstly we need to remember that
the taliban
government in afghanistan right now
is um you know it's it's a it's a
forceful
government it's not by the choice of the
people of afghanistan they had no say in
this
the taliban have captured that
you know those cities by force
even
even though they claim that they have
not
you know fired their guns but they still
were holding guns on their shoulders and
they still had their clash and corpse on
their shoulders so they are using power
they all you they are using uh their
their their you know their military
power to
suppress people to force people to
accept them
but also they are you know they
they're they're denying people their
basic human rights and they're not very
clear about that they are giving very
vague
statements on protecting the human
rights of people so i think you know
this is this is the time that
all the world leaders who speak about
protecting humanity and who speak about
standing up for human rights that they
stand up for the rights of the people of
afghanistan and
it's really important for them to
protect the rights of women and girls to
protect the rights of minorities
especially
but also ensure that all the
humanitarian assistance and aid is
provided to people there
we know that the presence of the taliban
has impacting the the lives of people
but there's also
you know other issues like covered and
severe drought as well so those issues
cannot be denied either like it's going
to a state of famine as well uh and and
these are issues that must be
considered so you know this is this is
what our advocacy and our activism is
asking for leaders to
to to act soon
you mentioned advertising activism
typically those are you know that's work
done by the government by the non-profit
sector
uh by foundations and so on a lot of us
here will graduate from the gsb and
enter the business community and the
private sector potentially what is the
role of businesses in the private sector
in partnering in various ways in solving
this problem
i think you know this is this is a
question and this is a challenge and uh
um you know i don't have answers
uh to all of these questions but i will
say that everybody has a role to play in
uh in showing support to those who do
not have a voice right now who do not
have the support that they need a lot of
people right now in afghanistan need
safety and there have been
you know many organizations including
like businesses who have helped in the
evacuation of so many people so i think
the top priority is to ensure that the
people in afghanistan especially the
activists who are
uh you know who are under threat from
the taliban that they receive safety and
protection and
you know we we did that for our
activists in afghanistan and for other
families and a lot of other
organizations and government officials
have done that for many families there
so that you know that is a
that is essential but along with that we
also need to explore other ways in which
we can use you know our expertise and
resources to make uh education more
accessible for children in afghanistan
and i think you know this is something
where business community can help how
can we use
the you know the technology that we have
to ensure that education is given to
girls in afghanistan in other ways
rather than formal schooling
and along with that i think you know
still like humanitarian assistance and
support is needed and businesses have
the opportunity to to support the work
that is happening there uh for
the safety and protection of people for
um
you know ensuring that they're given
their basic needs uh so again like there
are so many ways in which people can
help but it also requires like you know
collective effort to to think through
this and
uh and also like engage the people of
afghanistan in these conversations
mentioned technology um
i believe you recently had a partnership
announced with apple
based in silicon valley tell us more
about what's the vision behind that
partnership with apple
uh so
with apple um you know malala fund has
been working over the past many years
and apple has supported our projects so
it was also you know covering the work
that we are doing in afghanistan and
then other countries like nigeria india
pakistan and we run this activist
program which is called malala fund
education activists and we have i think
more than 50 activists in in all of
those countries right now and they are
working on addressing the problems that
girl face in their in their local
communities for instance like when kovit
started
our activists in nigeria they conducted
a research straight away and they were
looking at the impact of covet 19 on
girls education and they realized that
girls miss out on their education
because they don't have access to
digital tools uh they are also more
you know they're also more likely to be
forced into marriages when they are
stuck in their houses
and they also could be supporting their
families financially or in the in the
household chores
and uh so then they us our activists
they started doing lessons through
radios so they would ensure that you
know even if they even if the girls
cannot attend their schools because of
covid they're still learning their
lessons through radio and that is the
best
you know form of technology in those
areas like other technological devices
and tools may not work
and
so you know that is just one example of
how they are just ensuring that children
do not miss out on education and they
keep on learning so apple has you know
they are one of our biggest supporters
and uh and it's great to to work with
them that's great
so that's an example of you know your
time commitments your priorities
partnering with apple and um
you're obviously you know you travel
around the world do a bunch of speeches
you're meeting students you're also at
the grassroots level um you know
visiting refugee camps and schools and
so on
as you think about your personal time
where do you feel your own time is best
used in that fight against getting the
130 million drills back into school
what's most important for your time
i think like i'm always there
when my voice is needed and i was
very fortunate that i got the
opportunity to visit countries and to
join girls who needed their voices to be
heard i have been to nigeria iraq
lebanon jordan and
i have you know met incredible girls who
are fighting for their right to safety
and
education and many of these girls have
faced displacement and they have seen
wars and conflicts in their hometown and
they are living in you know in refugee
camps or informal settlements but they
have not given up on their dreams often
time like i'm expected to inspire them
but it's it's the other way around like
they inspire me and and everyone else uh
you know who
who uh who are joining us
and
like i i remember there was one girl i
met her name was najla in iraq
and she was a yazidi girl
and her family uh you know were decided
that she should get married she was only
14 years old and she was in her wedding
dress
and on that day she decided that she
does not want to be forced into marriage
she does not want to miss out on her
education so she took off her high heels
and she ran away to protect herself from
that
and then
you know later on when she came back she
tried to convince her father and her
family to allow her to be in school and
she started going back to school but
then when isis came into her hometown
they had to evacuate again and
now when i met her she was in this
informal settlement but she was still
passionate about learning and getting
her education and i saw that she was
carrying a dictionary with herself
where
you know and i asked her i said why do
you carry dictionary with you she said i
want to like learn a few words every day
so this is the passion that girls carry
for education and learning and despite
all the difficulties that they face from
walking for long distances and not
having all the resources like
books and and teachers like they still
are committed to
just receiving their education and you
know their
um and it was naturalized najla was
incredible
then she also like came to
the u.s and she spoke at the un platform
and she shared her story so my goal is
to meet these girls but also uplift
their voices so like leaders listen to
them rather than me and this is my goal
in every meeting that that i go to is
that the activists and girls are with me
and you know i introduce myself but i'm
like let's listen to najla let's listen
to these activists um and they have
something to say to you you have not
been you have been ignoring their voices
so hear from them and they will tell you
what the issues are in in this country
for girls and women that's beautiful
just hearing the stories themselves is a
lot more powerful
than advocates and so on and so forth
previously you've also mentioned uh
potentially um interest in politics is
that still on the road map what kind of
what's the shirt done with oxford what's
next uh no not yet
no interest in politics uh i think
um
you know it's
like when when i said that i wanted to
be the prime minister of pakistan at
that time i was 12 or 13 years old
and
i was really disappointed with the role
of our political leaders because what
was happening in swath was it was just
taking so long and for me it was just
absurd that no one would take any action
uh and as days went by and i thought
like girls in swat valley cannot go to
school
there's a conflict our schools are
bombed we're here
firing like every night we we are having
sleepless nights and our like we are
under threat and no one does anything
and it happens for two years
so at that time i said okay like
fine i asked you guys you didn't do
anything so i'll i'll one day become the
prime minister and i'll fix it but you
know then you know i'm i was really
fortunate that i have so much experience
and i have met so many amazing and
incredible people and i have been able
to visit so many like projects
i know that you know the world is a bit
more complex but
um you know you can bring change in many
ways you don't have to be a politician
to be a change maker
you can bring change in any role that
you take in your society from
becoming a doctor engineer business
person to a politician or to a human
rights activist all of these
opportunities gives us
some some ways in which we can
contribute to the change that we want to
see in the world so i hope to continue
my activism and ensure that we see that
day when all girls can go to school
and on the topic of change in many ways
there's this wave
of young activists
in the last few years and it's very
refreshing to see
you know the younger generation standing
up and having their voices heard
different activists advocates have
different styles in how they engage with
the issues that they're tackling the
community
how would you describe your style where
does that come from
what brings that out in you
i think for me there are a few rules
that i follow in my advocacy
one is that
my voice and my words should reflect me
and who i am and what my values are
so
and then along with that it's also
important for me that whatever i say is
the truth
so
as long as you are speaking
uh
you know the truth and as long as you
are yourself then you know that should
be
your you know your form of advocacy but
i also think that we are all in like
different positions and in different
places
and
you know some of us want to work from
the inside some of us want to work from
the outside and i think you know we all
have a role to play and we are all like
helping each other so i do not
underestimate or undermine the activism
that other people are taking in
different forms i think it's incredibly
powerful uh and
um and you know like all the activists
should just realize that they're all on
the same side
they're all on the same side and they
must support each other because that
helps them in achieving their goal they
have a lot more in common
and they must not lose focus on the
issues that they want to address and the
change that they want to bring so i you
know in the education field or in other
fields when there is activism happening
you know i
i appreciate the role of every person in
there
and speaking about different types of
activism and different clauses and so on
you know the malala fund in your vision
is for trolls education
but there are so many other
issues injustices
reported in the media some not even
mentioned in the media happening all
around the world
given your voice your platform malala
how do you think about
when to speak up and when not to
there are some issues that have impacted
me and that have been part of my story
and i think you know i should be
speaking out about those issues and you
know
that issue includes
girls education i speak out for girls
right to education all over the world
but then i also speak out about
uh what is happening like you know in in
parts of pakistan and afghanistan
because we had also been
part of that long decades-long terrorism
that the people have faced there uh
whether it's the pakistani taliban or
afghan taliban they have all
they all carry the same ideology and the
same acts and
we all
have have been their victims
so i speak out about that as well and i
speak out about the issues that impact
girls education
but there are other issues as well in
which
you know it it connects to girls
education and my mission but
sometimes like i'm not the best person
to speak out for that there are so many
other people who have expertise in that
and i ensure that the platform is theirs
and i support them
so
you know there are many things which i
do not speak out about uh because i just
want to show that
um you know that my voice is is for
girls education and that is understood
that this is my mission and this is what
i will i will use my voice for
yep
you know you're you're traveling around
the world um you're you used to be a
student as well you're judging a lot of
different things we see you on tv and in
the news uh very often
like how do you think about work-life
balance and just personal health like is
work in life is there even a blur or
is there a balance there um
i would say it was very difficult when i
was in school because you know i i used
to have homework like every day and i
had to attend my classes from like 8 a.m
till 4 p.m in the uk so it was quite
challenging and i remember one time i
had a flight to
norway to attend some event
and i think it was like over the weekend
or something but i was arriving like the
next morning in the morning time uh so i
i was like i can't miss my school days i
took my school uniform with me
and then on the way back i you know i
went straight to my school changed you
know into my uniform and and
i was like i can't go home i i would
miss my classes so
it was challenging uh but you know it
was important for me that i focus on my
education but also i give time to my
activism for the education of all girls
all around the world
but i had to focus on my education
because you know if you speak out for
education and don't focus on yours you
are
i think missing the points
great um is are there any like just
day-to-day
activities mindfulness is there anything
you do on a daily basis that kind of
helps you stay
committed to that work-life balance you
mentioned i really like you know staying
in touch with my friends and talking to
them uh i i like spending time with
people it could be like you know our
family friends and my own school friends
or university friends
and i you know i like playing uh
games as well as at one point it was
among us if anyone had played it
but then i i think we are all like done
with that right we have moved on
after that um
i like playing cricket with my brothers
and
badminton
and i
i watch tv shows as well i have seen
squid game so
the first episode literally shocked me
and i was like what is happening but
then after that i think you get used to
it so
uh that was that was good and then
in the middle i had to like stop i was
like okay i need to switch to something
else so i went to ted lasso and he made
me like
laugh and just
realize you know like life is more
positive and easy and
yeah but
got it
i want to move on to
you know there's a on to just perhaps um
criticisms that you face um
and it's shocking to me personally but
given the work you're doing the work
you've done
and what you've been through there's no
shortage
of pushback
why do you think um where does that come
from
where where is it where does it butt out
from that criticism
i think firstly it depends like what the
criticism is and if we like you know
clarify and explain that but
you know if somebody says that
you know i should
do this and not that and i haven't done
enough for this or that and like
sometimes i have to remind people like i
am not a government you know i i don't
have like trillions of dollars and i
don't have a central bank
and you know i i am not that person but
my goal is to use my voice and and the
resources i have to convince governments
to invest in education in women
and and ensure that the resources are
allocated into the right areas that
benefits our society that empowers women
and girls
but i think then there are also things
like you know but i but my focus is
always that i am working for girls
around the world and their right to
education so i feel like i'm only
unstable to myself and the people i have
made commitment to uh to ensure that we
make a better world other than that like
you know people can say anything right
um
and i think also like you know on social
media you see comments and things like
that and you would see like 20 positive
ones and just one negative one and then
all our focus is on the negative one
right we dismiss all the positive ones
uh but i think
it's it's important to remember that
sometimes the social media
world does not actually represent the
real world that we live in and i will
say that
um so far i have not seen anyone in
person who has been hateful to me
who has uh
been um
you know like has said anything negative
they have always been supportive and
even if they have been critical they
have done it in a very polite way um so
i don't worry too much about that that's
great
um specifically maybe indian and
pakistan
you visited since
since the attack the pandemic has
obviously made that more difficult
what is your long-term kind of ambition
of with pakistan and you know what you
want to see there and the role you want
to play there
um i hope i can go to pakistan more
often and
i was planning to go already but then
pandemic things made things a bit more
difficult
i have uh you know we have been working
in pakistan
since we started malala fund our first
project started from pakistan and that
was
to announce this this project which was
the education of 40 girls who were in
domestic child labor so to give them
education and they're still learning
they're still continuing their education
they're in like higher uh grades now
and uh since then like we have now
done even like you know more and bigger
projects since then we have started
a school in the hometown of my parents
shangla
and shangla is considered to be one of
the most deprived and and you know
areas in in pakistan it's a it's a
mountainous area and
this is the first school there first
school for girls there where girls can
complete their secondary education and
like every year we get hundreds and like
thousands of applications
and we can only pick a few students but
what you realize is that when quality
education is available
when the state of the art school is
available and
when parents feel safe for their
children to go to school
then like this this the the social norms
and um and and all that
all that like stigma that's been
associated with education for girls
changes really quickly and uh and we see
so many families like sending their
daughters to school and um so you know
like the the positive change has already
been seen and along with that we do our
advocacy through the through the
champions project and in pakistan we
have
many many champions and activists there
who we are supporting in their work for
gulf secondary education that's great
what do you miss most about living in
pakistan i i miss my home i was i miss
swat valley and shangla those are very
beautiful places
and
i miss my time with my friends
um yeah and the food as well of course
you know
i live in the uk so
i always miss the food
got it
um
so just before we kind of move on to you
know the audience questions
the mission in the vision malala that
you've taken on is vast it's 130 million
drills
you know we hope it happens
you know as fast as possible budget
multiple years and it's fairly long-term
vision
how do you stay motivated on a
day-to-day basis does that in a business
sense you can you know you can win a
deal and kind of see very tangible
success on a regular basis this is more
long-term how do you stay motivated on a
daily basis
i think that inaction has worse
consequences things remain as they are
so
keeping
your work going is important so staying
active is important for me and i believe
that the work that we have done and the
work that people in the past have done
for women's rights and girls education
and the in in the work that all the
organizations and everyone is doing
has brought us to this stage and
has helped us see progress so this work
needs to continue and we need to
accelerate it and we need to make it
better and we will see progress what's
what's
worse and what's
you know what
i think is is dangerous is
is us all giving up right so we should
not give up we should not stop this work
uh so we have to carry on
inaction is complicity yes
um the theme for our view from the top
speaker series is beyond expectations
and we like to ask all our speakers
malala
you know what motivates you
as a 24 year old girl from swath
pakistan to go beyond the expectations
of you know
from pakistan
um
i i am
very ambitious
and i was like that
in my childhood as well
and i
would always question
society and the world and why it could
not be better than it is
why do we see equality inequality with
our own eyes and don't do anything about
it why do we see that
like so many people live in extreme
poverties
why can't we change that why is it that
millions of girls are out of school and
nobody does anything about that
so i and but then on the other hand i
also remain ambitious that we can change
that we can see that change
in our own life
and uh
um so
this is something that i have
taken with me from my childhood
is that you have to remain ambitious
and um
and you know you have to be a bit more
optimistic
so i remain optimistic and ambitious in
my goals to see all girls in school
in you know in my lifetime
inshallah
um great let's open it up to audience
questions
i believe we have one
right over
um hi malala my name is taliha and i'm
an mba one here as a fellow pakistani
woman um it is incredibly inspiring to
see you here thank you so much for
coming here
um my question is as someone who's
personally navigated the challenges of a
patriarchal society i know there are
millions of girls and women back home
who personally face restrictions whether
it's access to education whether it's
professional opportunities or even
simply to have an independent opinion of
themselves
on a more personal basis what is your
advice to them in terms of keeping hope
alive for a more freer future what was
the thing for you that allowed you to
continue staying so resilient in your
difficult times
uh thank you for that question
so i'll share one story when i started
um you know speaking out in my activism
i was only you know 10 years old but
then as i was growing older and i was
you know at age 13 and 14 and especially
like in our society in the north of
pakistan
it's you know it could become
a taboo for a girl to be on a tv screen
and
you know and speak out to media publicly
not cover her face and some families may
completely oppose that and i remember
like one time
my dad asked my cousin to take me to
this press conference area
and you know my cousin just felt
extremely uncomfortable and then he told
my dad that you know that malala should
not speak and
my dad
told him that this was none of his
business he should not be deciding
anything for his daughter and that
everything that malala does should be
her own choice so
but today like that same cousin
is the biggest supporter
of my cause and he's actually involved
in in the work and he is so passionate
about girl's education and he supports
me in my work
so
like initially you would see
this um
you know this unease among people you
might even
hear
you know hateful comments or you might
hear people feeling just very
uncomfortable to see women in different
roles and in different positions and
women women having a loud voice and
women being at the table but with time
they'll get used to it
and and you know in in a few years like
before we know it things things have
already changed and things already
become like customs and new norms uh so
it's important for us to remain
uh ambitious and committed and its
consistency is really important so we
have to stick to it and ensure that you
know we we carry this work on
and
and hopefully you know things things do
change we are already seeing so much
progress in pakistan we have women in in
the parliament and we have women in
different jobs and in different sectors
and
you know hopefully like it it will get
better it will improve uh and a lot of
women are speaking out about like
women's safety at work and in other
spaces and they're speaking out against
you know harassment and sexual
harassment so this is there is
there is this
campaign going on for women's equality
in pakistan and that gives us hope
next question
here
hi malala i'm bruno mba1 here from
stanford just be so first of all i would
like to thank you for sharing your
thoughts your brave story
definitely motivate us to make the world
a better place
well i'm from developing country in
latin america where education is not a
right it's a privilege
and i feel very privileged to be here at
stanford
as i know many boys and girls they
didn't have the opportunity to go to a
proper elementary school in my home
country that is brazil
so i would like to ask you what what are
your thoughts about our role as students
from top universities like stanford
oxford to minimize the gap between basic
education across the countries
uh thank you for that question i think
you know you are all
uh the future of
this world you are all the future of
your countries and
i would say that remain
ambitious about your goals
and you can you can bring change in your
countries you can bring change in your
communities
and you already might be a role model to
so many young kids
who may not have thought about
themselves
completing their school going to a
university and taking a role in society
so you know you are already giving hope
to so many people
so many women especially here who could
be coming from developing countries or
from uh you know difficult backgrounds
they're giving hope to so many women and
girls and when when a child
sees somebody else in their dress in
their outfit
and and you know when they see somebody
who looks like them
they they can imagine themselves in that
person's role so you know you are
already giving hope to so many
another question yeah
um hi milano so my name's harpreet i'm
an nba too
um and you may not remember this but we
met a long long time ago
do you remember
so in all fairness wrestling the reason
she won't remember
is because she'd suffered a very bad
infection and she was in icu after
having just been shot in the head
the reason i remember is because i was
your doctor at the time
um and i've followed your journey ever
since the difficulties you've had
integrating new cultures followed you
through your new school and hmas and
high
tried to be part of the malala fund when
i was at mckinsey as well
i thought i was a natural fit
but i come from a family of strong
feminists and i've benefited from that
as well but i have seen a massive
conflict
in tradition versus progression and
culture
and i know we've asked a similar
question but now that you've lived like
you've had the pakistani experience
you've had the westernized experience
what do you think you can take
from the experiences you've had
in the western world
and how do we take them back to areas
where they could benefit
um
thank you for that question and you
thank you for all your support and nice
to see you again
i
think for me like you know when i when i
started living in the uk
there were so many things that you know
surprised us we were
living in cold weather forever and uh
you know we were missing our nice warm
summer days in pakistan but other than
that you know we i started studying in a
school where
you know we were getting quality
education that was the first time when i
realized that education is not just
about sciences and maths and learning
english but students also learn
you know cooking and sports and textiles
and these are not the subjects that you
often see in schools in pakistan and it
really challenges you to think about
education in different ways
in which you know the goal is not to
make somebody a doctor or engineer only
but to ensure that anyone
can go to that institution they can
explore their
their
you know their abilities and they can
explore uh you know their their
specialties and then realize and and
reach that that their full potential so
when i when i was uh you know studying
in the uk i realized that
you know education is is not just
limited to like sciences and um and like
maths and those subjects
uh but then also like along with that
you know there's a good health system
and
um you know you are much safer and
uh but you know like your home is your
home and you miss so many things about
your home you know when you are with
your friends and family and
you are you know sitting
in your
um you know in
in in your
sort of dining room with your with your
family friends and you are enjoying nice
food and
uh you are surrounded by this beautiful
valley and these lush green hills you
are you're happy and you're still having
like a joyful time
so
i think for us like even though we were
having all those facilities we would
still miss pakistan all the time
uh what i
you know i
i and i have seen this in many places
people consider like the west to be sort
of the standard of prosperity and
development and i think we need to sort
of
uh challenge that a bit uh
because the pandemic and the recent
events have exposed how the systems in
many countries are not the ideal systems
they are still not favoring the most
marginalized people in in society they
are discriminating against people based
on their income background based on
their skin color based on their gender
uh so we need to like
um be a bit more critical of the system
that we idolize and uh you know it's
possible for pakistan and other
countries to improve their systems and
and this is a challenge for countries
all over the world to improve their
systems to ensure that
they provide welfare to all its citizens
and it's based on a just and equal
system so nobody is left out and
nobody's treated unfairly
great um thank you for those questions
before we end malala we left to run with
a lightning round so i'll i'll share a
phrase and just
give you a quick thoughts um on those
ready
yes yes okay perfect
this one should be easy okay
dad lasso or squid james
ted
lasso so is that apple tv over netflix
or something i mean i'm partnering with
apple tv it has to be ted lasso
it's the right answer um
uh yeah by the way like i started a
productions company extracurricular just
for the context and we're partnering
with apple tv plus
so yeah it has to be dead last
favorite queer eye actor
i i don't have any names i'm so bad at
names so you can you can suggest and i
can pick one jonathan van ness but no
no i'm i'm i'm bad at this no worries no
worries no very sorry the only name i i
usually like when you talk about actors
and actresses like i know all the
bollywood ones
um
and
then like i know brad pitt and
leonardo dicaprio and that's it
okay
how about this one a world fitter who
you have not met but want to
a world figure
at that point um
so
it's um
i so um okay
it's not a politician it's not a
politician but
uh i really want to meet vanessa nakate
she's a climate activist and i
have been following her journey and i
would want to see her in person right
favorite social media platform
i i mean it has to be instagram no no
it no i think it's twitter i think it's
twitter it's hard to pick but it's
between those two
sometimes it's twitter i mean like when
anything happens you you want to go to
twitter right
just just see tweets on it and then
instagram is also good um
but yeah like whenever i'm following
cricket i just go straight to twitter
and just see what people have have said
it's very funny same year yeah
where do you store your nobel peace
prize
that's confidential you'll never know
okay great and then last one favorite
adele sand
um
[Music]
i would say hello hello great
awesome well malala this has been a lot
of fun for me personally and for you as
well and we appreciate your time
thank you so much thank you absolutely
thank
um
thank you
thank you
thank you so much
thank you so nice to see you thank you
thank you
[Music]
you